- [Hannah] They say pizza? I say, yes.
Whoa.
- [Jackson] SpaghettiOs
- All right.
Jackson asked to make pretzels
Mm!
- [Jackson] And the trailer.
- [Hannah] Yes!
- [Jackson] Sour.
- [Wyatt] Grass pizza.
- [Hannah] It was truly one
of the most beautiful days
we've had it a very long time.
Hi, I'm Hannah.
I'm the world's OK-est mom
and I have been really boring
and tired this past year.
It's true. I been very overwhelmed.
I've been on autopilot and
I've been really tired.
And so I want to kind of
reinvigorate the fun in our family.
I'm bringing back an old video.
A very long time ago, I only
said yes to my kids for a week.
At the time they were very young
and I want to see what it looks
like now that they're older.
So, for one week, I'm going
to only say yes to my kids
to everything they ask for. Wish me luck.
So here's the plan.
I really don't want
them to catch onto this
because I don't want their requests
to snowball and escalate
into something I can't do.
But, my hope is that it creates
some fun, memorable moments
for us and also new ways
for us to bond together.
The rules pretty much stay the same
as the last time we did
this. It's gotta be a secret.
They can't find out that I'm doing this.
We got to keep it clean.
They have to bathe, they
have to brush their teeth.
They have to do personal hygiene.
But the little addition
this time around is it
has to be pandemic friendly.
We can't be planning
things that aren't safe.
We're taking our walk, our
usual neighborhood walk.
Whoa, almost hit me.
The first thing the boys asked
for was surprisingly easy
which I was not expecting.
They asked if we could
take our neighborhood
walk that we like to take.
Nice.
Of course the first thing
they asked for isn't crazy
because they have no idea what's going on.
So, I really should have known
that it would have been an average day
for that first day of me trying this.
So here's hoping it will stay this way
for the rest of the week.
It really didn't take long
for the weird food requests
to start coming in.
- SpaghettiOs
- [Hannah] You want
SpaghettiOs for lunch at 10 30?
- Yeah
- [Hannah] Okay.
- They're so good.
- [Hannah] Go ahead.
- Wyatt has always been
really difficult at mealtime.
He doesn't like sitting down for meals.
He doesn't like finishing
all the food on his plate.
So this actually clued me
into maybe his hunger pattern
is a little bit different
than my meal schedule.
And I might need to adjust a
little bit for him to make sure
that he's eating enough
and also enjoying his food.
As a parent, I'm always learning.
And so that taught me a
little bit more about Wyatt.
- Jackson asked to make pretzels
homemade soft pretzels today.
I would have never said yes to this.
They take forever to make.
But, I had to say yes.
What do we have here Jackson?
- We have yeast, sugar, salt and water.
- [Hannah] And then what is this?
- [Jackson] Flour.
- Yep. Our dough is coming together.
Give it a slap.
Like this, there we go. This
a little fat boy pretzel.
- I do this.
- [Hannah] Give it a try.
- Twist it.
- [Hannah] Careful not to `drop it.
(Hannah and Matt laughing)
Look at that!
This thick boy. Oh my gosh,
I did not feel like making these at all.
I'm so glad we did. They smell fantastic.
Mm!
They were a little fluffy.
- Amazing.
- [Hannah] Did you guys do a good job?
- Mhm.
- [Hannah] What do you want Henry?
(Henry cries)
You want me to hold you? Okay.
Even Henry gets yes.
Are you happy now?
- Mama.
- Baby.
(baby talks)
Yep. By day three, I'm
pretty sure the boys
were catching on because they asked me
for something I would never agree to do.
All right. What did you ask me to make?
- I asked you to make
a yummy candy platter.
- Candy platter. All
right. Let's get started.
- Yeah!
- I love candy TikTok.
So, there are all these
amazing candy shops on TikTok.
With these cool candies that
just looked so fun to eat
and so the kids will sometimes scroll
through and watch with me.
So, they finally asked
if we could get some
and make a whole candy platter
of all these crazy candies.
It's a hundred percent my fault.
I'm showing them videos
of awesome looking candy
and then expecting that
they're not going to want it.
Yeah. Right. So, I
should have known better
but secretly I wanted an
excuse to try it, too.
- Try our magic potion.
(whistle)
Sour.
- Cotton candy. Mm.
(spring)
- Tastes just like Dr. Pepper.
Weird. Swabs are cool
because you can just make
your own shape lollipop. Mm.
- It's a gummy tomato.
- We had a nice long
teeth brushing session
after all that sugar and they were
over the top hyper the rest of the day.
I really couldn't tell
if they were on to me.
I don't think they fully realized
that I was only saying yes
Wyatt has made a dare request.
What did you ask for?
- Grass pizza.
- Grass pizza?
- Wait with real grass?
Now I would go out and find some grass
except the fact that I live in the desert
and there's literally no
grass anywhere out here.
So that's off the table.
I'm going to have to get really creative
about something edible
that also looks like grass.
I have my grass; basil and cilantro.
Grass?
Kind of.
Grass pizza, enjoy.
- Oh, grass.
- Jackson liked it. Jackson
likes everything. He's easy.
And then, you know, Matt
coming in clutch with
- [Matt] Mm mm. So good.
- All right.
Oh, hi honey. You want some?
(jazz music)
You like it?
- Grass pizza.
- So Jackson asked, where
are we sleeping tonight?
- In the trailer!
- In the trailer.
- One weekend when I was
gone with the kids, Matt went
and bought a travel trailer.
Here's Ziggy.
I wanted one for so long.
I just think they're so fun
and portable and cute
and so multifunctional-
that I've really wanted one forever.
We named it Ziggy because
it has the cute little lightning bolt.
And it's just perfect.
So when Jackson requested
that we all sleep in the trailer together,
I got very excited because
it would be my first time.
Okay. Here we are. In Ziggy the trailer.
The boys initially wanted all of us to
sleep in there, but Henry
really couldn't sleep in there.
There was no room for all of
us. So Matt stayed in the house
with Henry and I stayed in the
trailer with the older boys.
Welcome to the trailer.
- Hi, Henry
- I forget how fun it is
for all of us to play cards together.
Ha!
- Momma, do you have a four?
- Yeah.
Are you happy to be in here?
- I forgot to wash my face but too bad.
Did you brush your teeth? Did Wyatt?
- I don't think so.
- Oh, geez. Well he's out. He's asleep.
Alright, goodnight everybody.
- Goodnight.
(Hannah yawns)
- How'd you sleep? How'd you sleep?
- What?
- How'd you sleep?
- I'm watching Big Time Rush.
- I slept terribly
because I- having a baby,
I wake up anytime someone startles
cause I just get up with
the baby in the night.
And I was sleeping between two
of the most restless sleepers of all time.
So every time they moved I'd wake up.
- I want my decaf caramel macchiato
with my little breakfast
sandwich with some-
bacon in it? Yeah. And eggs.
- [Hannah] I want my decaf
caramel macchiato. Oh my gosh.
- That tastes good.
- A lot of you have noticed
in the last few episodes that Wyatt really
enjoys this one pair of elf pajamas.
So this week I couldn't make him change.
I couldn't say no.
He wore his elf pajamas
to his heart's content.
And we just went with it.
As the week progressed,
the boys really wanted
to get out of the house.
So they asked if we
could go to Pioneer Town
which is pretty close to where we live.
But it is really the
spot you want to go to
if you want to do something
outdoors, that feels very safe
and isn't super crowded
cause it's a lot of wide open spaces.
You hungry?
- [Jackson] Can we get lemonade?
- [Hannah] Yes.
- I'm hungry for chips.
- [Hannah] You hungry for chip? Yes.
- [Jackson] Lemonade! Lemonade!
- [Hannah] Lemonade.
Are you guys enjoying yourselves?
- I finished my lemonade.
- [Hannah] Oh wait Henry. Oh my goodness.
Jackson also asked if
we could take a walk.
Wyatt didn't want to go
and Jackson said good
cause I want it to just be you and me.
And so I happily obliged.
What are we talking about?
We're gonna talk about
some Minecraft mods.
- Minecraft mods, yes!
- It's hot. We can take
our mask down for a second
cause nobody nobody's around.
I like our time together.
This is my buddy.
- Can we have barbecue tonight?
- Barbecue?
- Yeah.
- Yay!
- Do you want to barbecue
or do you want us
to order barbecue?
- Barbecue.
- You want a barbecue?
- Yeah.
- All right.
- It was nice that Jackson
asked to take the walk because
that's pretty much all we
can do one-on-one right now
and if he's happy to do that,
I'm happy to do it with him.
Final day! I knew
something big was coming.
I just didn't have any
clue what it would be.
Where did we go Jackson? It was so cool.
We're at the beach.
We went to the beach!
- Oh, the beach!
- We haven't gone to the
beach in the longest time.
Going to the beach is a lot
of work when you have kids.
But this time I couldn't say no.
So to the beach, we went.
Wyatt, what ya doing? Were
you gonna build a sand castle?
It's a beautiful day! It's so nice out!
And we brought some sandwiches
and it's going to be amazing.
- I'm having the best day ever!
- The boys loved the beach
so much. It was truly one
of the most beautiful days
we've had in a very long time.
The boys asked for pizza for
dinner. I'm on board with this.
- Yeah, I can't wait.
- I'm excited. They say pizza. I say yes.
When we went to pizza,
Henry got his first
official slice of pizza.
(background conversations)
- What?
- [Jackson] It's now all red.
- [Hannah] Sweet brother, oh my gosh.
Look at the sweetest brother.
While I was saying yes
to the boys this week,
it really opened my eyes to the fact
that my mood sets the tone for the day.
And if I'm taking care
of myself and taking
care of my mental health,
I'm setting the tone for
the rest of my family.
It really reminded me that my kids' needs
at the end of the day, their
core needs are very simple.
It's not this like wild,
grand gesture that makes them happy.
There are also all
of these small moments
that also make them happy.
So that's all for now.
Let me know on Instagram what
you thought of this video.
If you have any more fun ideas
for us to try while we're still together.
If you'll please excuse us,
we got a lot of games going,
a lot of activities going.
Who's this, your Western friend?
- Tom, Tom.
- Tom.
- Cowboy.
- Until next time, bye!
- Bye!
_ Wyatt, you want to say bye?
- Bye.
- [Jackson] Turn off the camera.
(outro upbeat music)